it is so good to see both of you
no we're trying to compliment as many
people coming on here as possible
oh that's about the most well we go way
back
way back way back yes that's
dwayne i mean how's your mom doing very
good
thank you very much and how's your
family your your daughter i think yeah
yeah
yeah that's two two girls yeah but
talking about girls emily i have to say
i absolutely loved you in this character
as lily because i watched it with my
girls
and to see this powerful kick-ass woman
take it on when you're usually a man
what does it mean for you that girls are
going to be inspired
by lily i love that they will i love
that they're going to see this
trailblazing
character she was a trailblazer for her
time you know in 1917 where there's so
many
ridiculous constraints on women and she
just kind of threw through that
it's like she throws caution to the wind
and sort of leaves that in the dust and
i really admire
and she left off the page and she's got
this really adventurous spirit so
yeah i love it she's hopeful she's cool
you were absolutely perfect for me
she hates when i say this because i
started this but but it's so true and
i'm glad that people are watching the
movie now and
doing the comparison themselves but she
really turned into
she delivered this performance it's like
the female version of indiana jones
and that's saying a lot and that's with
all due respect and reverence so much
pressure
but you really did you really did
somebody there emily i'm a huge fan of
yours and i know dwayne is too and i
think even kevin hart's gonna be jealous
that you have this connection together
but it would be so
bummed exactly what is it like for you
to be able to
work with emily this is the new one yes
what's it like working with emily duane
oh what
yeah you just missed a very important
question what's it like working with
emily yeah yeah
don't cry you see that you need no i did
this
i was getting ready to say something
very dirty
no um i would say
blink i know it sounds emotional yeah
i working with emily has been uh
let me finish with that can you please
yeah
working with emily has been phenomenal
she is
i've always admired her in the past and
the work that she's done
uh within our business
uh she calls it stalking i call it an uh
admiration but
um but the truth is singita when we
started working together i realized in
these moments that ah this is why she
is uh she will go down as one of the
greatest
actors of our time of our generation i
mean she when you look at her
range of the films that she has done and
these powers she has a
real power she hates this she hates it
but she does she brings a real soul
quality and a power to these roles and
she did this
uh in jungle cruise and i was so happy
to create this
to help create and make this movie with
her but also
where this film is seen through her eyes
and through this emboldened female
superhero in a way that little girls and
little boys and men and women around the
world can really look up to and that
guts
that they have that she has that comes
from in here
i can't say enough great things about it
sending a virtual hug
take care everyone
you